the global apocalypse never looked as
stunning as it does
in the midnight sky for those who've
finished the film
and may want a deeper dive into what
happened let's break down
everything that happened at the end
beware spoilers
the final moments of the midnight sky
really bring home the connection between
augustine and sully with the reveal of
just a single word
iris early in the movie we learned that
iris is the name of the little girl who
appears to be
accidentally left behind with augie in
the research lab
and who becomes his companion as he
makes way for the lake haven satellite
station
to make contact with ether though
augustine is initially reluctant to take
care of her
especially given his own state of
constant inebriation and declining
health
he eventually grows very fond of the
child and does
everything in his power to protect her
as the closing moments of the movie show
little iris is just a figment of
auggie's imagination
but she is based on a real kid
flashbacks to auggie's younger days
revealed that his jilted lover gave
birth to a daughter
and he got to see the child from a
distance once his memory of the girl has
informed his version of iris
while that girl grew up to be known as
sully
and i'm iris
i know augie didn't make verbal contact
with iris
as a child which is probably why his
apparition does not speak
but he finally gets the chance to
communicate with his daughter and steer
her from the danger in the end
by the end of the midnight sky it's
clear that augustine
is not long for this world after he
successfully connects with the crew of
the ether
at the satellite outpost there is little
left for him to look forward to
he will likely not be able to return to
the larger research facility since his
snowmobile has been lost
and the same ice crumbling accident that
cost him his vehicle
also left his pack of chemotherapy
treatment supplies at the bottom of the
freezing lake
augie mentions several times that the
world is now uninhabitable everywhere
i'm afraid we didn't do a very good job
of looking after the place while you
were away
and a satellite image of a smoke clouded
earth confirms the same for those on
board the ether
auggie knows it's a matter of time
before his desolate region of the world
is also consumed by the radiation
it's clear that he knows there is no
hope but audiences don't
see him actually perish as a result of
his condition
the final shot of auggie does reveal a
sense of resolution for him
however as he steps into the wintry
outdoors to observe the night sky
as the ether passes by for its final
voyage he holds the fictional iris's
hand
one last time with a smile seemingly
acknowledging he has completed his
mission to keep her safe
both sully and adewale ask augustine
about potential
options for re-entry but he insists that
the only
habitable places left are underground
and even those are temporary
however there are two astronauts who are
convinced that they must return to earth
mitchell and sanchez we're going home
for mitchell it is both a matter of
completing the mission as
it was originally prescribed and also
taking a chance
no matter how slim it might be at being
reunited with his wife and two sons
once the communications mechanisms are
restored he belatedly receives a message
from his
wife letting him know that his sons are
sick and they are all being evacuated
whether they are in a safe place
underground is unclear
but mitchell always calculated mortal
dangers to himself into his line of work
so he remains willing to risk it sanchez
joins him because it takes two crew
members to operate the reentry pot
and he wants to escort the body of their
fallen crewmate
maya back to earth he may not have any
family back on earth
but maya reminded him of the daughter he
lost many years before
so he feels this is a worthwhile effort
both men appear to know however that
they are unlikely to survive upon
returning to the inhospitable planet
though mitchell and sanchez return to
whatever is left on
earth sully and adewale decide to
implement
augie's plan to slingshot ether around
the planet and return to k23
a moon on jupiter that augustine had
previously pointed to as potentially
habitable
the aether's initial exploration of the
locale proved that his theory was
correct
and sully knows from her personal
experience on the ground that k23 boasts
breathable air and other resources
during her final conversation with
augustine sully takes the opportunity to
communicate with him
about what this new world is like
[Music]
it's amazing
[Music]
the colony site it feels like colorado
beyond the viability of life on k23
sully and adewole have yet another
reason to return there
instead of earth sully is pregnant with
adewale's child
a daughter whose potential name became a
point of conversation
and jest between the crewmates before
their fates were made clear to them by
the restored comms devices
what they will ultimately name the child
is undecided by the time they begin
charting their return to k23
but the little one has obviously given
them another reason to retreat to a
survivable alternative to earth
[Music]
i guess it's just us now there are
several themes to be found
throughout the midnight sky but the
prevailing message of the story
is the importance of human and
particularly familial connections
augustine's entire journey including his
fabrication of a young iris
is his way of coping with what he has
lost by not spending more time with his
real child while he had the chance
augie has been purposefully isolated
from others and single-mindedly focused
on his work
even declining the chance to evacuate
with the others from his research
facility
his cruelty to and dismissiveness of
sully's mother
is what made it so that sully doesn't
know that augustine is her father
but she still admired his legacy so much
that it inspired her to join the space
program
with death looming for him and the world
at large augustine finally reckons with
the fact that deep down he did want to
be a father to iris
and both his imagination and actions
come together to make her safe
one last time he seems to find ultimate
peace when he hears from sully that she
has followed his career
and that she is grateful to him for
steering herself and attawole back to
k23
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one